A tragedy no child should bear.
Ten children from the same family were on
their way to school when they spotted an exploded
bomb on the ground, a common sight in Afghanistan.
They picked it up.
The deadly device went off.
Three children were killed.
Seven survived, but they lost at least one
limb each.
More than a year later they are struggling
to adapt.
The day when the blast took place, it was
a bad day.
I saw my brothers and sisters soaked in blood,
lying on the ground.
My entire family was destroyed.
The children are tutored at home, but sometimes
they have to go to school for exams.
It's not an easy journey.
Blisters form where the artificial limbs rub
their skin.
A painful reminder of their new reality.
When the explosion took place, I tried to
stand up and go home, but when I tried to
walk, I noticed that I didn't have my leg.
This was a year ago, after the blast that
changed everything.
Their story, a reminder of the war that still
rages on, even though the Taliban are in negotiations
with the US for some sort of peace settlement.
A resolution seems far off.
Decades of conflict have left the nation strewn
with landmines and other deadly devices.
The UN says more than 900 children were killed
in 2018.
Another 7000 were wounded.
If peace comes, we will be very happy, there
will be no problem, everybody will be doing
their business without any tension, even if
we have disability at least we will have security
and peace.
Everyday there is non-stop fighting and gunfire
and it has made our life terrible.
The Afghan government and the Taliban must
sit together and agree on peace, so other
children do not get killed or get disabled
in this war.
And though her childhood was taken away, Rabia
hopes that other children in Afghanistan can
still enjoy a normal childhood.